if you're an archicad user you may or
may not have heard of ci tools what ci
tools is it is basically just a series
of tools provided by graphisoft on top
of your existing subscription to make
your workflow significantly easier and
quicker so the main fundamental
essential elements of ci tools are the
roof coverings and the wall coverings
you also have the added benefit of the
slab covering tool but we won't cover
that too much today first of all let's
start with a wall covering tool so if we
were to select any random wall and just
draw a single random leaf let's just
draw a box for the purpose of argument
all we have to really do is select any
of our walls that we want to activate
our ci tools on we want to go to our top
menu in ci tools we want to come down to
coverings and we want to select wall
coverings what you're then going to see
is a new dialog box pop-up with a series
of all sorts of settings the main
settings that you want to be looking at
from the get-go is the covering section
right here so built into ci tools is a
series of pre-defined coverings which
basically allow you to do what you
really want to do in great detail rather
than creating a new texture for example
we can instantly go to our weatherboard
and you'll see there is a genuine
weatherboard automatically created in 3d
rather than trying to emulate that with
some sort of texture and texture detail
so with ci tools we have a number of
these different patterns first of all we
can go absolutely no wall covering
completely removed we can come down to
our generic board which is basically
something like plywood you can use that
as an example and a would be the
thickness of the actual board in itself
and b would be the bracket or the
furring channel behind or in front of
the timber so for this instance if we
were going to go for a 35mm furring
channel that would sit on the outside of
our wall and then an additional 30 mil
of plywood or whatever this material is
in your case which would mean our wall
would increase by 65 millimeters if we
continue to scroll through these
elements we can go to a board and bat
system which is extremely useful if
you're trying to create that nice board
and bat effect we can manipulate it
rotate it do whatever we like we also
have bricks and blocks if you want to
create a reverse brick veneer wall or
brick veneer wall potentially even use a
brick facade
on something like a precast concrete
wall use this as some sort of stone
effect you can use this covering to
basically emphasize exactly what you're
trying to do and be able to detail that
properly next we have our basic
corrugated look so if you're looking for
some sort of tin fencing roof covering
anything in a corrugated look you can
manipulate and change this to exactly
how you see fit next we have logs as an
example which could be used as a
retaining wall system to give you that
nice log wood effect in addition we also
have panels which this one is extremely
complex and you can manipulate it and
play with it as much as you want we're
basically seeing a panel set up that is
depicted by these elements here so if i
only wanted that to be 1200 by 1200
squares we could change this if i wanted
my thickness to be 50 ml a nice thick
profile or let's say i wanted the cut in
to be quite deep quite steep large we
can emulate and change any of these to a
real world object and a real world
cladding material we could even go ahead
and change that to a 45 degree angle to
create something completely different
that you usually don't see in archicad
we also have a ribbed pattern which is
basically
a high profile corrugated metal that can
be used in any sort of architectural
cladding i use this one quite a lot it
is an exceptional profile if you get the
settings correct next we have our
standard shiplap shiplap smooth we have
our shingles if we were gonna go for
something a little bit different we have
our vinyl weatherboard and we have our
actual weatherboards themselves so from
the get-go we have a series of very
important very critical cladding
elements that we can use to enhance our
architecture so to give you a good
example of what exactly we're talking
about 3d take a look at our cladding
system what you'll see is we've got a
weatherboard effect rotated on a 90
degree angle which is completely
inaccurate to what we would usually have
so if i was to select all of these
claddings which are independent to the
actual wall structure change that back
to zero
we'll have a traditional horizontal
pattern weatherboard that if i zoom in
close enough you'll be able to see the
3d elements that i was talking about
previously now let's say we want this
one here to be a completely different
product we come into our weatherboard
let's go boards and battens let's change
that to a 90 degree orientation press ok
and there we go it's a completely
different cladding already attached to
that existing wall being completely
unchanged now these coverings can go
even more in detail so if we go command
t open up the settings again we can
scroll through and we can change our
corners in our external and our internal
corners how we want to see that
connection detail so at the moment i
have a regular we can go beveled we can
go through all of these settings
basically to make it exactly what we're
looking for that applies basically to
all the corners the tops the bottoms
everything in between the joins between
the claddings the horizontal trim the
wall tops head height seal heights
basically all of your openings you can
go through all of these settings one by
one change every piece individually one
by one so if you wanted your seal
cladding to be a different color to the
head cladding you could go in and change
that if you wanted your jams to be
bigger than your seals for some odd
reason you can go ahead and do that you
have full flexibility control in this
one 3d element now if we come back to
our ground floor plan and just simply
create a very quick roof we'll see that
arcade basically creates a very generic
roof structure that doesn't really give
you too many options or too much
flexibility especially when trying to
detail properly so if we clicked on our
roof went back up to see our tools up
the top clicked on coverings went to
roof covering this time instead of wall
covering again using the same methods as
we previously discussed coming straight
to our cladding we can have flat roof
corrugated ribbed shingles spanish tiles
or just normal tiles at our disposal
within seconds so if i simply clicked on
corrugated pressed ok we would instantly
have a corrugated roof available for us
to document and continue our project
with incredible accuracy now for
instance if we wanted this section of
the roof to be something different or if
we wanted a different gutter profile we
could simply go into our settings come
down to our flashings for example let's
say we didn't want a flat flashing we
wanted a square ribbed and let's say we
come down to our gutter we didn't want a
quarter round gutter we wanted a square
gutter on that profile pressing okay
we'll see everything has changed very
rapidly very quickly we have a square
gutter as opposed to our quarter rounded
gutter we have different flashings this
system isn't always perfect so if you're
creating a complex roof structure
sometimes shows your hips and your
valleys and your gutters in the wrong
place we can come back to our ci tools
coverings edit roof edges and we can
double click on any of these lines that
are depicted by our roof structure below
and change what we're actually seeing so
for some reason that wasn't a hip it was
a barge i could easily click ok
and it would be changed to a barge so if
i delete this section you'll see that
we've created a barge on this side of
our roof coming back to coverings
editing that again
double clicking on that barge going back
to a junction and pressing ok
it automatically changes back to a
junction now one of the best things as
well is if we wanted to come back into
our floor plan select one of these roofs
you'll see these pink little hot spots
at the end if i select one of these hot
spots drag them out ever so slightly
show my floor below as a trace reference
just so i can see where my actual wall
is connect that back to my wall and come
into 3d we'll see that it's created a
down pipe for me automatically that i
can simply extend to the bottom of my
wall
and manipulate this however i saw fit
now in my experience arcad 24 has had a
few glitches with the ci tools coverings
but arcad 25 is working phenomenally
well there is no glitches so if you're
using the 4d library windows as an
example the windows and doors packages
the 4d library in archaeo24
won't cut these coverings perfectly
however in arcade 25 it cuts them
instantly so as an example coming back
to our ground floor plan let's simply
just drop a random window in the side of
our project and there you go it is
instantly cut into that cladding it
creates your head seal and jams that you
don't have to go ahead and create that's
all from me my name is david tomic i'll
see you next time